the documents obtained by sky news on
islamic state are an extraordinary
intelligence resource
their sheer scale is impressive but even
more valuable
is the level of detail well it's a
fantastic
coup and it will be an absolute gold
mine of information of enormous
significance and interest
to very many people but of course
particularly the security
and intelligence services in fact there
hasn't been anything
at all like this really since the
discovery of the sinjar records they
were called in
2007. one telling detail
who recommended them to the islamic
state it will give them an indication of
not just who they are where they come
from but
will be able to potentially lead them to
the people that radicalize these
individuals as well as facilitated
their departure and it's those people
that are really key
it's these people that are capable of
radicalizing and sending out foreign
fighters
in the dozens this is what we've got
here i mean it's huge amount of
documents but let's take
how exactly though will the security
services make use of this unique
detail understanding the ways in which
people were recruited
how they traveled what connections they
made on the on the way there is hugely
important because we've learned over the
last
two or three years that it's the
relationships that allow you to
map the the provenance but also the
capability of is to recruit
and retain people and these networks are
the basis of
possible future recruits as well so i
think this is very significant
the cache includes 22 000 documents
each document has 23 fields giving more
than half a million
points of data in total that might sound
like a bewildering amount of data for a
human to wade through but that's where
machine intelligence comes in computers
can
plug in this data look through and
create entire network
structures of the islamic state and
hopefully find links that human analysts
would miss
the documents also contain categories
for level of obedience and time and
place of death
those could be useful encounter
propaganda it is an information war with
the islamic state as much as anything
else
and this is a huge weapon tom cheshire
sky news